monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues
la première année du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro ont marqué au delà du
tout pour la finance par le choix d'un
libéralisme sans frein de la casse du
droit du travail à la sélection
renforcée pour entrer à l'université en
passant par la déstructuration de la
sncf semblait quoi après coup consolider
un grand fatalisme une sensation que
dans un paysage politique exploser la
résistance ne pouvait s'organiser
la voie semblait libre pour les
apprentis sorciers du cac 40
ses partisans d'un nouveau monde sans
droit sauf pour les plus forts mais
l'attitude jupitérienne du président de
la république sont arrogants son
jusqu'au boutisme libéral symbolisée par
la suppression de l' isf ont provoqué
l'explosion de la colère populaire qui
s'exprime depuis maintenant cinq mois
les discours sans fin les en même temps
permanent les petites phrases méprisante
à l'égard du peuple ont accompagné cette
politique de démolition méthodique des
derniers vestiges du modèle social
français issus du programme du conseil
national de la résistance
depuis des décennies la solidarité recul
en france les droits les plus
fondamentaux pourtant reconnue par la
constitution comme le droit au travail
le droit au logement le droit à la santé
à l'éducation ou à une retraite digne
ces droits sont aujourd'hui bafoués des
décennies de renoncement ont amené à la
profonde crise économique et sociale
mais aussi démocratique que connaît
notre pays
comme l'ensemble du monde occidental la
clé du renoncement l'alpha et l'oméga du
libéralisme
si la primauté de l'argent sur l'être
humain élu président de la république
emmanuel macron a prôné un nouveau monde
qui bien vite est apparue pour ce qu'il
est un régime libéral à l'autoritarisme
croissant usant et abusant de coups de
com pour masquer les grands bonds
l'arrière sur le plan social et
économique alors la colère est venue
elle a éclaté depuis vingt-et-un une
semaine la france vit au rythme du
mouvement social et citoyen le plus long
de son histoire la longueur de cette
secousse souligner la profondeur de la
souffrance
vous avez peiné monsieur le premier
ministre à juguler la violence qui
inévitablement accompagne ses colères
aux actes illégaux de quelques-uns que
nous avons condamné avec force
vous avez répondu par une répression
systématique et démesurée du mouvement
jamais jamais vous n'évoquez ces
centaines de blessés ces dizaines de
mutiler éborgné est ce ainsi que les
hommes vivent écrivait le poète s ainsi
que ce qui relève la tête ceux qui osent
dire non doivent être considérées cette
violence monsieur le premier ministre
vous ne l'avez pas évoquer même d'un
souffle ni au grand palais n'y ait ni
ici à mille lieues des ronds points
ce grand débat monsieur premier ministre
n'est pas celui de nos concitoyens
tous les chiffres le montrent sur 45
millions d'électeurs inscrits auxquels
s'ajoutent des millions de jeunes en
mesure de comprendre et d'agir comme ils
le font sur le climat seuls 500 milles
soit 1% à peine du corps électoral ont
élaboré des contributions ce chiffre est
en lui-même fortement contesté et un
million et demi aurait participé à des
débats ce chiffre n'étant pas
contrôlable
quant aux conférences régionales huit à
neuf français sur dix tirés au sort ont
refusé d'y participer
pourtant ce grand débat aurait pu
rassembler être autre chose qu'une
tentative de contournement de la colère
populaire
mais emmanuel macron dès le départ a
écarté les thèmes de justice sociale et
de justice fiscale qui fondait la
mobilisation
pas question de rétablir les sf pas
question d'augmenter le smic
pas question d'imaginer une nouvelle
démocratie symbolisée par le rite
d'ailleurs monsieur le premier ministre
votre réaction à ce rich ou au rip
apparaît surtout comme symptomatique
d'une crainte de l'expression populaire
monsieur provini je ne suis pas née de
là
asnières pluie mais quand même
l'opération à laquelle nous assistons de
faire passer ce grand débat pour
l'expression du peuple est sidérante
plus c'est gros plus ça passe pour être
votre adage est celui de monsieur macro
la france qui souffre la grande majorité
de la population n'a pas été représenté
ou si peu ce sont les diplômés des
classes les plus favorisées des plus
âgés alors que les jeunes étaient
carrément absents qui ont participé la
belle photographie que vous voulez nous
vendre comme une reproduction parfaite
pour légitimer votre fuite en avant
libéral est totalement faux c'est la
preuve alors que 77% des français de
mode leur équipe or le rétablissement de
l'iace f10 6,3 des contributeurs au
grand débat il serait favorable
90% des sondés souhaitent un abaissement
de la tva sur les produits provient
nécessité 13 % seulement des
contributeurs plus de 80 % des français
sont favorables au rhic 5,6 pour cent
des contributeurs
quel décalage ces chiffres montrent bien
que ce grand débat tourne à la grande
autour groupe emmanuel macron et vous
même monsieur le premier ministre
prenait un grand risque non seulement
vous tentez une grossière manipulation
pour justifier le nom renault et un
entêtement dangereux mais vous masquez
la poursuite des coups bas contre les
intérêts populaires semaine après
semaine mois après mois
sincèrement quelle hypocrisie a parlé d'
écoute alors que vous vous obstinez à
brader au privé aéroports de paris et la
française des jeux
écouter le peuple oui et une bonne fois
pour toutes si vous avez un doute sur
adp accepter le référendum pourquoi
quelques conseillers financiers aux
grands argentiers aurait-il raison face
à la foa la volonté de millions d'hommes
et de femmes avec les 240 premiers
parlementaires signataires de la
proposition de loi référendaire
je mets au défi emmanuel macron de
lancer une telle consultation populaire
de même vous affirmer avec des trémolos
dans la voix
la nécessité de rapprocher les services
publics de la population monsieur le
premier ministre
vous venez de déposer un projet de
démolition du statut de la fonction
publique
en confirmant la suppression de 120
mille fonctionnaires et vous asphyxiez
toujours et encore les collectivités
locales même logique avec votre annonce
d'une augmentation de 5 6 % de
l'électricité dès cet été monsieur le
premier ministre
le piège s'est refermé sur vous si si
pour appliquer le programme d' emmanuel
macron vous ne pouvez pas répondre aux
attentes populaires
et pourquoi et bien tout simplement
parce que votre logiciel politiques est
incompatible avec les espoirs de nos
concitoyens pour preuve la petite
musique de la nécessaire réduction des
dépenses publiques est déjà là mais
jamais jamais vous n'évoquez la
scandaleuse évasion fiscale et
l'enrichissement sans fin des des
détenteurs de capitaux
c'est logique vous êtes là pour les
servir ce sont vos soutiens à des
sceptiques vous maquiller le désir de
justice fiscale en volonté de baisse des
impôts et avant tout pour les plus
riches et les entreprises quant à la
justice sociale salaires ou retraites
seul votre règle d'or celle de
l'austérité prévost monsieur le premier
ministre avec emmanuel macron vous
prenez ce risque celui de démultiplier
la colère et ces derniers mois montrent
que l'histoire n'est pas écrite vous
prenez le risque non seulement de
décider de décevoir mais aussi de
susciter le désarroi
pillon de susciter la haine
l'histoire aurait pu retenir le souvenir
d'un pouvoir qui auraient choisi
l'écoutent et la raison malheureusement
tout montre que vous vous apprêtez à
faire le choix de l'entêtement celui des
privilèges au détriment de l'humain de
cette humanité ou qui ont purgé dans les
épreuves l'histoire de notre pays mais
n'oubliez pas monsieur le premier
ministre qu'une idée devient une force
lorsqu'elles sont pas des masses et
aujourd'hui les masses ont beaucoup
d'idées